Thanks to Paradox for sponsoring
a portion of today's video.
Oh, okay. I got all the samples we need.
We're really gonna blow this theory wide open.
MatPat to Enterprise, one to beam up.
Oh!
Wait, wait, wait, wait. Something's not right.
We're losing him. This shouldn't be happening.
Tell me.
Why do we keep using these things?
Hello, Internet. Welcome to Film Theory,
the show that boldly goes
where no show has gone before.
Well, except that other time we
went where no show has gone before.
Yeah, it's been a minute since we've
talked about Star Trek on this channel.
Three and a half million minutes, to be exact.
Over seven years.
And man, has the series really
seen a revival since that time.
Sadly, there haven't been any more movies,
but did you know that between
streaming and YouTube,
there are more Star Trek shows released
after our previous theory than before it?
Wrap your head around that
one. It is mind-blowing.
And there are even more on the way.
Just saying, all you Trekkies out
there are eating good right now.
But beyond the strange new
worlds they're exploring,
the one thing I'm most excited about
is the potential for new memes.
Feels like it's been too long
since we got a new Picard facepalm,
or sarcastically surprised Kirk, or...
Kirk!
Really, it's impressive how many lines from
the Star Trek series have just
entered into everyday speech.
You got, He's dead, Jim. And
set your phasers to stun.
And of course, the all-time classic,
Beam Me Up, Scotty.
For all you Zoomers watching who only recognize
that as something your grandparents say,
this was the catchphrase that everyone
in the original Star Trek show would say
when they were ready to teleport back
to their starship, the Enterprise.
See, the original Star Trek was made on the cheap.
And I mean, the cheap cheap.
That's why all the costumes
looked like bedazzled sweaters,
and the alien planets looked like
they were made from papier-mâché.
It's probably because they were
bedazzled sweaters and papier-mâché.
And because they didn't want to blow
the budget on every episode flying
down to whatever new world they were visiting,
they invented a form of teleportation
known as the transporter.
That basically cost the production team nothing.
You just step into a tube, get
surrounded by glitter, swirling in water,
filmed upside down in slow motion,
and then you get beamed wherever you
need to go as long as it's in range.
Honestly, it's a cool piece of sci-fi tech that's
helped to craft the utopian future
that Star Trek is so well known for.
Or did it?
See, the transporter's been the topic of
discussion amongst the fanbase for a long time,
with a bunch of philosophical debates around
whether or not the person who
steps out of the transporter
is the same person that went in.
See, the way the technology
works in the canon of the show
is that it breaks the people it
transports down to the atomic level.
It then beams them to where they need to go,
and then it reassembles them there.
So, is that really the same person,
or just some weird copy with all
the same thoughts and memories?
It's a classic ship of Theseus debate,
which I can now cite without
having to explain too much
because you all know it from
the finale of WandaVision.
CGP Grey actually has an excellent
video covering that exact discussion.
Today, though, we wanted to
throw our hats into the ring
and do something a little bit different with it.
Switching our phasers from
philosophizing to analyzing.
Because I think there's a truly dark secret
lying here inside this piece of technology.
One so dark, and so devastating,
that the citizens of the Federation should
be running as far and fast as
they can to avoid this thing.
After diving back into the Trek series,
I'm convinced that the transporters
are weapons of mass destruction
that could also be potentially
poisoning your brain.
Yep, after this one, you're never gonna dream
of stepping aboard the Enterprise again.
Put on your red shirts, friends.
We're beaming aboard.
So, first of all, what are
the transporters exactly?
Well, they do exactly what they sound like.
They break you down, atom by atom,
and then transport you from one location
to another in a form of teleportation,
reassembling you on the other end.
But how does that actually work?
Well, there are a few steps.
First, whatever's being transported is scanned
by the machine down to the molecular level.
Then, as the original series put it,
The molecules in your body
are converted into energy,
then beamed into this chamber and
reconverted back into their original pattern.
Okay, that's a bit of a technobabble solution,
but for the sci-fi setting, sure.
Checks out.
And that certainly looks
like what's happening here,
with all the characters dissolving into light
and then reappearing from the same sort of light.
But just on a surface level,
there are some pretty horrifying things that can
come from this sort of technology malfunctioning.
The Star Trek shows actually get a lot of mileage
from these sorts of accidents in their storylines.
Beam the captain and Spock back up?
We don't have the power.
They'll come aboard, amass a dying flesh.
And I realized there's no margin for error.
One atom out of place, and
poof. You never come back.
Believe me, we'll be talking
a lot more about them today,
but let's actually think
about what they're doing here.
They're converting the matter of objects,
people, clothes, hair, what
they eat for breakfast,
all of that stuff, and turning that into energy.
That should be setting off some
alarm bells in your brain here.
And this is our first big reason why no
one should be using the transporters.
They're very easy to weaponize.
See, whenever you start talking about
converting mass into energy and vice versa,
there's a very real and very famous scientific
equation that lets us do exactly this.
In fact, it's one of the discoveries
that Albert Einstein is most famous for.
E equals mc squared.
All that equation's talking about is energy
equals mass times the speed of light squared.
It's a pretty simple equation, right?
Sure, but the result is some crazy huge numbers
when you consider that the speed of light
is almost 300 million meters a second.
So, squaring that, that means you're getting a lot
of energy from a very teeny tiny amount of mass.
This is the idea that nuclear
energy was based off of.
Seriously, did you know that a chunk of uranium
the size of a golf ball in a nuclear reactor
can produce more energy than 3,200 tons of coal?
This is why.
And that's with modern-day technology
that's awful at converting mass into energy.
We only get a fraction of what's available to us,
and we're left with a ton
of unusable waste afterward.
But if you can convert
matter into energy perfectly,
like these transporters would need to do
if they're moving people around intact,
well, to convert just a single gram of
matter to pure energy with 100% efficiency,
that would be equivalent to
89.9 terajoules of energy,
or the energy released by the
detonation of over 21,000 tons of TNT.
If you scaled it up to an average-sized human man,
right around 200 pounds or 90 kilograms,
Einstein's equation means that you're getting
an energy equivalent of this crazy number.
That means nothing to you? Fair.
Basically, that would be the
same as 54,000 explosions,
just like the little boy bomb dropped
on Hiroshima back in World War II.
In short, the Star Trek transporters
have the potential to be some of the
most devastating superweapons in the universe,
an explosive more potent than
anything we've ever seen on Earth,
which you could just set off from anywhere
you'd like within the range of the transporter.
Oh, I'm sorry, you're getting
bullied by a Romulan warbird?
Just transport a Tic Tac on board and let
it blow up instead of rematerializing.
And before you jump down to the comments to
tell me I'm wrong and this would never happen,
yeah, I do realize that there are
certain safeguards in place in the show.
Throughout all the episodes
of Star Trek I've watched,
there's never once been an accident
caused by the matter-energy conversion.
But there have been many people who've modified
and weaponized their transporters before.
Throughout the franchise, we see
transporters disable weapons,
weapons get modified with transporter
tech to shoot through walls,
even replacing people
mid-transport to invade a ship.
Given all of that,
is this sort of matter-to-energy
bomb really that much of a stretch?
Or is it more of a storyline
that's yet to be written?
Now, before we explore the other horrible
ways using a transporter could go wrong,
let's take a moment to thank our sponsor
for today's video, Paradox Interactive,
and their newest game, Star Trek Infinite.
Star Trek Infinite is a 4X strategy game.
Basically, the point is to explore,
expand, exploit, and exterminate,
all very much in line with the many
factions of the Star Trek galaxy.
You can choose to play as the
Federation, the Klingon Empire,
the Romulan Star Empire, and the Cardassian Union.
Of course, because I'm a goody two-shoes,
I jumped at the chance to play
my first game as the Federation,
and so I quickly started exploring every system
that I could, but things got tense in a hurry.
The Romulans attacked a Klingon
colony, leaving thousands dead,
and it was up to me to broker a peace.
Did I do it? Well, to be honest, I haven't
gotten to the end of that campaign yet.
There's so much to do in Star Trek Infinite.
It's one of those games where you get into it,
you blink, and suddenly 16 hours have passed.
What blew my mind, though, was learning that each
of the different civilizations have
a completely different mission tree,
each one focusing on the things that
lore nerds like me love about the show.
Sure, I played as the Federation, so I did a
bunch of diplomacy, negotiations, and exploration,
but if you play as the
Klingons, they focus on warfare.
The Cardassians are great at spying.
The Romulans are masters of stealth.
All of those story focuses
line up perfectly with what
we see from the civilizations in the Trek shows.
That, plus the fact that so many of
the story events pulled from things
that actually happened in the Star Trek universe,
tell me that there was just a ton of love
and effort and care put into
the crafting of this game.
If you're a giant Trekkie
and enjoy 4X strategy games,
then you have to check out Star Trek Infinite.
Thanks to Paradox for sponsoring
that portion of the video.
Now it's time we beam back
down into our discussion as
to why the transporters should terrify you.
So we already know that putting a human
into a transporter would create enough
explosive energy that you
could wipe a planet clean.
But the horrifying scientific implications of
these futuristic inventions don't just stop there.
See, when you break things
down to the atomic level,
you can do way more than just move those
atoms around and piece them back together.
You can also rearrange those atoms
to create something brand new.
And we see this concept used all the time
in the form of Star Trek's replicators.
A replicator is a machine that
can create and recycle things.
Replicators were originally used
to synthesize meals on demand,
but in later series, they were used
to create larger non-food items.
As Commander Riker explains,
You've seen something as fresh and tasty as meat,
but inorganically materialized, out
of patterns used by our transporters.
Materialized by our transporters.
So, the replicators are using the same
matter-to-energy conversion technology.
It's taking an existing
reservoir of matter and energy,
and using those components as
building blocks to copy a pattern
stored in the computer of whatever item you want.
Say, for instance, a nice juicy steak.
It's kind of a lot like a 3D printer.
But then, where are they
getting all that matter from?
Obviously, they don't have some other steak in
some other room teleporting onto your plate,
and they're not creating matter from nothing
because that's scientifically impossible.
It has to come from somewhere.
So, where's that steak from?
Poop.
Crapola.
We actually learned this in Star Trek Discovery.
It's made of our s***.
That's the base material that
we use in our replicators.
We deconstruct it to the atomic
level and then reform the atoms.
Pretty good for s***.
Yep, everyone in Star Trek is literally just
eating poop rearranged at the subatomic level.
I don't know if intergalactic
peace is worth the price.
No, I'm not just bringing
this up because it's funny.
Things get really creepy when you
take this to the logical extreme.
If the replicators are using the
same matter-energy conversion
technology as the transporters,
and the replicators are basically
able to create things from scratch
using a basic set of atomic building blocks,
could you just print out clones of humans?
Yeah, 100% you could.
And that isn't even something
that we need to speculate about.
I'm Commander William Riker from
the Federation Starship Enterprise.
That's not possible.
I'm Will Riker.
Yeah, this happens multiple times throughout the
course of the franchise with varying results.
Brad Boimler's cloned in a transporter
accident in Star Trek Lower Decks.
Captain Kirk was also split in two
during the episode The Enemy Within,
which not only cloned his body, but
divided his personality between them.
The most famous example of this, though,
is a transporter accident from The Next
Generation and the episode Second Chances,
where you see William Riker materialize both on
the Enterprise and back on the planet
that he was being transported from.
This second Will Riker was
more or less his own person,
taken on the name Thomas Riker,
complete with a personality
distinct from Will based on
their different experiences after being split.
This, of course, prompts a lot of
philosophical questions raised by the fanbase.
Even the show isn't sure which one
of these is quote-unquote real.
Which of them is real?
Well, that's the thing. Both.
You were both materialized
from a complete pattern.
But even if we don't want to
get philosophical about this,
think of the practical ramifications here.
What's to stop someone from modifying a
transporter and making a clone of someone,
anyone, they wanted, at any time, they wanted?
That person would have no paper trail.
No one would know they exist, and
that has some dark complications.
They'd be a perfect assassin, a
perfect alibi, a perfect victim.
That right there, that is horrifying.
Most importantly of all, the transporter
clone would absolutely be made of poop.
And not only can transporters make
copies, they can also create new life.
In the Voyager episode Tuvix, two of
the ship's crew, Tuvok and Neelix,
are accidentally combined into a single
life form after a transport gone wrong.
This new creature is named Tuvix.
Get it? It's their names combined.
You guys, I see what you're
doing there, Star Trek.
Can't get sneaky stuff like that past me.
Anyway, during the transport, the pair's DNA
strands merge to create something entirely new.
Again, this opens the door
to horrific moral quandaries.
Tuvix is his own person with
his own thoughts and feelings,
and so obviously he's not gonna
be all that keen on dying.
So when the opportunity arises to
bring the two crew members back to life
by pumping Tuvix back through the transporter,
Voyager's captain is faced with a terrible choice.
To this day, whether or not
this was the right thing to do,
or if it was outright murder,
has challenged the fanbase.
All because of these dangerous transporters
and how they have uncertain effects
on the people they're teleporting.
No one tell the Trekkies
that Tuvix could have lived.
They just could have brought back
the other two as poop clones.
Now, creating clones and fusions of people
who go through the transport
process is a terrifying concept.
But the worst one for me,
reason number three you should
never use a transporter,
it has the potential to slowly drive you
insane until you're erased from reality.
Transporter psychosis is in fact a
real thing in the Star Trek universe.
Transporter psychosis was
diagnosed in the year 2209.
It is caused by a breakdown of
neurochemical molecules during transport.
This disease affected motor
skills and reasoning ability,
and caused paranoid delusions,
dementia, and hallucinations.
In universe, they eventually found the
cause of transporter psychosis and fixed it.
But for a while, especially
during the era of Captain Kirk,
every time a character was transported,
there was a chance that they
would literally lose their mind.
But you see, the fact that this is just a thing
that can and has happened
in the Star Trek franchise
got me wondering, what else could
these transporters do to your head?
What's the worst thing that
these could be used for?
Clearly, what's normal for a transporter is that
you go in conscious and you come out conscious,
remembering all the same stuff.
That's fairly consistent for the series.
But if you really dig into the lore of this thing,
you're also conscious while
you're being transported.
In the Next Generation episode, Realm of Fear,
the crew of the Enterprise
beam over to a derelict ship,
but they run into some trouble.
I'll have to send you over one at a time,
Commander, because of bandwidth limitations.
And the transport cycle will take a bit longer.
How much longer?
Four or five seconds, about twice the normal time.
The extended transport cycle is
played up for drama in the episode,
because one of the crew, Lieutenant
Barclay, has a transporter phobia.
Smart man, considering everything
we've been talking about today.
But the reason that I bring this episode up,
is that we actually see the transport
cycle through Barclay's eyes.
He experiences the whole thing multiple times.
And this isn't unique to just Barclay.
Have you ever seen anything during transport?
Sometimes my visor picks up resonance
patterns from matter-energy conversion.
This proves that you're
conscious during transport.
You're aware of your body being
split apart and reassembled.
Now that, in and of itself, is weird.
And it creates a complementary portion of
existential dread with your instant teleportation.
But on the whole, thankfully it's
over in just two to four seconds,
so at least it's short.
But what if it didn't take
just a couple of seconds?
What if you got trapped
mid-transport for whatever reason?
Well, it's something that's happened before.
In another Next Generation episode, Relics,
Scotty from the original series
saves himself from dying a slow death
by locking himself mid-transport
within the pattern buffer.
In basic terms, he was transported,
but then intentionally never
rematerialized on the other end.
So he just existed in this ethereal
state of unbeing for decades.
Additionally, something that they
don't touch on in this episode
is the fact that, given the rules
and logic we just figured out,
Scotty should have experienced
all of that time mid-transport.
In the actual show, it doesn't seem like he
realizes exactly how much time has passed,
but if characters like Barclay experienced
what it was like mid-transport,
Scotty should have as well.
Can you imagine?
Decades completely isolated.
Unable to move or, well, do anything,
but still fully aware of every minute of it.
That would wreak havoc on your brain.
You know, it's funny.
In the actual episode, Scotty did
this to himself to save his own life,
but I can't think of a more perfect way
to trap, imprison, and torture someone.
To force them to be alive and aware in
this state of unbeing all intentionally.
That right there?
That is horrible.
And you know what's even worse?
The cherry on top, this replicated poop sundae?
Listen to this.
Completely intact.
There's less than .003% signal degradation.
Your pattern can degrade,
meaning that you can literally lose
parts of yourself within the transporter.
That right there?
That is a real thing that's
possible in the Star Trek universe.
In fact, it happened in this very episode.
Another unseen character was also put into
this limbo state alongside Scotty, but...
His pattern has degraded 53%.
He's gone.
You hear that?
His pattern degraded, more or less killing him.
So not only is the transporter
potentially the perfect prison,
the ultimate form of complete
isolation and torture,
it could also be a way to just slowly
pick you apart over the course of decades.
Any way you look at it, the transporter
is a terrifying piece of technology.
Not only does it have the potential to create
explosions more powerful than
anything we can produce today,
not only can it create clones of the people
it teleports or combine them together,
not only does it potentially reconstitute
the people who use it out of fecal matter,
but it can literally alter your
brain and leave you in a limbo as
you slowly lose both your mind
and your body to the pattern.
You know what?
After hearing all that, please, PLEASE, for
the love of Kirk, do not beat me up, Scotty.
But hey, that's just a theory.
A FILM THEORY.
Aaaaand cut.